[Música]
quando eu era criança meu sonho é ver a
acho que toda criança tem um pouco disso
né
e vocês podem pensar a criança é fácil
basta acreditar e acreditava
tem dia que acreditei que podia voar em
sair do supermercado com o meu pai e eu
não tive dúvidas
eu corri e pulei de altura mais ou menos
uns dois metros e meio três metros se
muito que podia voar
as únicas coisas que eu consegui foram
quase matar meu pai do coração
algumas escoriações o corpo e vários
hematomas mas voltando a salvar o mundo
não acredito de verdade que as pessoas
que são enviadas parecer planeta elas
vêm por esse motivo pra fazer diferença
é claro que muitos de nós quando crescem
acabam acreditando que a si próprios já
estão fazendo um grande negócio
naquela época eu não tinha noção eu
queria mas eu dava indícios que já seria
alguma coisa um pouco diferente porque
eu colecionava joaninhas
e eu era o empreendedor porque chegou um
momento que eu tinha tanta harmonia
tanto a joaninha que eu resolvi claro
que era uma forma lucrativa de libertar
essas joaninhas porque nenhuma criança e
conseguir furar a joaninha na mão e
quando as manias voava e a gente ria e
eu até achava que tava vendendo
felicidade e tem um dia que eu descobrir
que nem todo mundo é igual porque teve
um que chorou mas esse chororô tudo mas
ele chorou tanto que a mãe dele resolveu
ligar pra minha mãe pedindo que no dia
seguinte eu levasse uma joaninha para
ele e para ele comprar e conhece a foi o
fim do meu negócio
sem contar que no dia seguinte escola
tia joanne ó sem contar que no dia
seguinte a escola inteira tinha
joaninhas é de graça mas também não me
deixei abater no final de contas o bom
empreendedor é aquele que corre atrás
das oportunidades né
as oportunidades não aparecem né
a gente cria e eu sinto que eu comecei a
vender raspas de lápis de cor
eu ficava horas e horas apontando lápis
de cor trabalhado na paciência
principalmente uma criança que tinha uma
certa e hiperatividade mas estou falando
tudo isso pra vocês porque quando fui
convidada da excited eu pensei agora eu
vou falar o que vão fazer e passou um
filme na minha cabeça
deve ser muito parecido com aquelas
pessoas que estão à beira da morte é que
o filme passa pela cabeça provavelmente
foi alguma coisa assim que aconteceu e
eu comecei a perceber que cada coisa que
acontece na vida da gente
ela acontece cá nos preparar para a
próxima coisa que vai acontecer
e hoje embora continue ainda é querendo
salvar o mundo
eu quero é ser feliz como a maioria das
pessoas que chegam numa determinada
idade e no meu caso eu procuro isso nas
pequenas coisas como o sol batendo no
rosto o vento
o sorriso ea alegria dos filhos ou então
tal pé da letra com as coisas pequenas
porque eu trabalho com nanotecnologia
coisas que são milhões de vezes menor
que um grão de areia
não é fácil você trabalhar com que você
não vê não é você tem que acreditar como
quando você era criança
então essa história de que há o que os
olhos não vêem o coração não sente bem
aqui ó tem nada disso
enquanto os olhos não vêem o coração
regenera
o coração acelera o coração para o que
os olhos não vêem as plantas sempre as
bactérias sentem a célula sempre a
nanotecnologia ela pode invisivelmente
matar apenas as células cancerosas e
indizivelmente ela pode despoluir as
águas invisivelmente ela pode
contrabandeada n ha para dentro das
células e como fantasma ela pode
lentamente liberar substâncias no
organismo
a nanotecnologia despontou ela nos anos
2000 quando os primeiros resultados
começaram a aparecer e de lá pra cá ela
tem aumentado vertiginosamente e tem se
espalhado nas mais diferentes áreas
não que a nanotecnologia não existisse
afinal de contas é negativa sob a parede
devido à nanotecnologia ea flor de lótus
ela fica limpinha lá no meio do pântano
de vida na tecnologia
é que a gente não via e hoje a
nanotecnologia em todas as áreas é aqui
no brasil nós temos vários grupos que
trabalham com tecnologia e muitos deles
são referências internacionais
nós podemos aplicar na tecnologia desde
uma célula solar até uma tatuagem
inteligente uma tatuagem que muda de cor
muda de figura
conforme a substância que está correndo
nas suas vezes existe um ted educação
bronz que é bem interessante ele fala
sobre isso é um que eu recomendo
embora as pessoas pensem na tecnologia
apenas em relação ao tamanho eu vou
dizer pra vocês que esse mundo é muito
mais do que isso
o grande problema são as regras quando a
gente tem um material que está na escala
macrométrica e ela passa pela escala
nano
ele altera suas características e com
isso as regras mudam
eu vou tentar explicar quando você toma
um café e esse café com pouco açúcar
você vai lá e coloca mais açúcar nescafé
e ele fica mais doce
mas quando a tecnologia pode ser que
isso não aconteça
é como se você colocasse café é r o
açúcar e quanto mais açúcar você fosse
colocando menos doce ele fosse ficando
então as regras elas não estão
totalmente claras e aí o que eu tenho é
que a gente sabe que esse material a
hora que ele começa a ter uma quantidade
muito grande
ele começa a agregar um no outro
juntar e com isso ele sai do mundo o
nano
essa saída faz com que muitas vezes pt a
atividade que ele tinha uma coisa que é
clara é que existe uma coisa que chama
área de superfície e quanto menor o nano
material maior a sua área de superfície
e maior a sua actividade devido a isso a
gente tem diferentes possibilidades em
relação também ao tamanho
então essas regras elas não estão claras
diz muita gente não gosta muito disso
alguns jogadores eles querem jogar
apenas em regras claras mas existem
aqueles que estão aí né
as coisas novas outra coisa interessante
é que quando você trabalha com no
material que ele é único e com isso não
posso generalizar
por exemplo eu não posso dizer que
emanam partícula nanopartículas de prata
elas são tóxicas
não posso porque existem aqui podem ser
tóxicas mas existem as que não são
e alguém vai falar isso é por causa do
tamanho né as maiores elas são tornam
tóxicas as menores não porque o mundo
não é muito mais do que isso eu tenho
várias características que eu tenho de
olhar eu tenho forma eu tenho tipo de
nanopartícula área de superfície
eu vou ter o qual o material que foi
utilizado para fazer é pra ser feita
essa nova partícula como ela foi
sintetizado e daí mediante de tantas
possibilidades diferentes eu acabo tendo
diferentes tipos de danos materiais
eu tenho no fibras nanotubos no cápsulas
nanopartículas são tipo poliméricas
nanopartículas metálicas e cada uma
dessas eu posso mudar muito
basta eu alterar a algumas das suas
características mas a partir do momento
que a nanotecnologia chegou
e com ela a cura do câncer pareceu se
possível assim como a gente tratar de
doenças que as bactérias resistentes
causavam a nanotecnologia passou a ser
co muito legal
embora isso seja uma coisa interessante
né
existe um problema porque na tentativa
de ficar na moda
a gente acaba tendo alguns trabalhos que
não são de boa qualidade principalmente
para aqueles que não trabalham na área
porém embora tudo isso nós temos imensa
possibilidade e eu vou citar algumas
aqui pra vocês
por exemplo é a 6 ante a dor meias que
trazem nanopartículas de prata que são
bactericidas né e com isso as bactérias
não se desenvolvem
imagina a deus chulé eu tenho um amigo
que muito ligado nessas coisas de
economia de água né ele virou assim
nossa renata
isso é interessante essa - nem ser
chamada é só que agora saiu a versão
correta
uma outra coisa que baseado lá na aquela
flor de lótus que nunca se suja
é só vocês já viram na internet eles
criaram tecido né e também no sujo o que
vocês virar derruba café e milho
derrubar suco limpinho
os carros não tem mais se esqueça não se
preocupe na hora de estacionar não se
preocupa com nada disso não vai mais
existir aquele de passar a chave né
no carro esqueça porque os carros estão
saindo com tintas que possuem na
tecnologia como se fosse no boletim no
cápsulas que é o menor risco
tenho
touro e refazem a pintura vidros
utilizando nanotecnologia também já
estão no mercado
ele repele qualquer coisa água sujeira e
com isso os carros estão saindo sem
padres para abrir uma outra coisa seria
a janela autolimpante não que ela não
surge ela surge porém agora que cai a
primeira chuva a estátua do link na área
da saúde nós temos pasta de dente com
nanotecnologia lnnano cristais de cálcio
que deixa os bons dentes mais limpos e
mais brancos nós temos também é filtros
solares que o nano partículas titane em
vários cosméticos com nanocápsulas que
carregam vitaminas carregam outras
substâncias que são importantes que
antes disso eram muito difíceis de serem
absorvidas e se ver se faço é só chegar
em casa e olhar os produtos que têm na
tecnologia
eu tenho um monte lá é também nós
podemos pensar na área da studio sport
nos esportes nós temos a canoagem e do
ciclismo e estão usando nanofios obras
que são muito melhores riqueza no fibra
de vidro muito mais resistente e muito
mais leves raquete de tênis
o hidrogel que também é muito mais leve
e muito mais resistente
podemos ter é embalagens comestíveis e
também podemos entrar para as frutas com
nanotecnologia em geral eles usam
nanopartículas de cerâmica
imagina isso quando você tem que
transportar uma carga de um local num
bem longe a há a chance de estragar
vai ser muito difícil e com isso você
vai melhorando um pouquinho esse mundo
no filtros
a enana membranas que podem limpar as
águas podem fazer à disposição dessas
águas
nós temos na nossa língua não nariz que
consegue sentir sabores né e sentir
odores uma capacidade muito maior do que
o ser humano na agricultura nano
agrotóxicos ano botânicos nanopartículas
biogênicas e tem uma que é muito legal
camisetas à prova de bala essa eu achei
que ele superará o que acontece
eles colocam nanotubos de carbono e
grafeno no alimento das lagartas do
bicho da seda e a hora que ela produz o
fio
o produto esse produto ele é super
resistente
embora a gente tenha diversas produtos
né ea nanotecnologia tem dado muito
certo
a gente sabe que ainda tem um longo
caminho pela frente
esse caminho pode ser trabalhoso
esse caminho pode ser adiado mas quando
a gente tem bons resultados
isso é incrível ea gente se sente como
herói e como tentava david bowie the
hill diz fã dele
então podemos ser herói por um dia eu
sou renata lima são nano cientista e com
a nanotecnologia eu conseguir realizar a
maioria dos meus sonhos
obrigado